okay it is I I don't know that I can say
it's officially the 2022 midterms right
now but at least in the context of the
former president Donald Trump jumping in
full steam ahead on the 2022 midterms
things are getting going Donald Trump
has added another endorsement this is an
extremely polarizing endorsement this is
exactly the type of endorsement we were
waiting for of an incumbent lunatic
trumpian Republican to show us yes
Trump's going to be involved Donald
Trump has now endorsed radical lunatic
extremist disgusting Republican
congresswoman from Colorado Lauren
bobert
or Lauren Beau bear as rokana called her
I kind of liked when Roe said
congresswoman Beau bear
sounds like a completely different
person Donald Trump putting out this
endorsement laced with erratic
capitalization which I will mention
um endorsement of congresswoman Lauren
bober congresswoman Lauren bobert has
done a fantastic job in her first term
representing Colorado's Third District
uh I can't think of anything she's done
but okay she is a fearless leader a
defender of the capitalized America
First agenda and a fighter against the
capital l loser rhinos and capital r
radical capital D Democrats she will
continue to be tough on Capital C crime
strong on capital B borders and always
protect our Under Siege Second Amendment
Lauren has my Capital C complete and
capital t total capital E endorsement
for her re-election why the random
capitalization we still don't know
someone wrote to me and said oh you know
Trump is German and in in German you
have capitalized nouns and that's not
what Trump is doing guys I can assure
you Trump has no idea what's going on in
German
um so what's interesting about this okay
we suspect that Trump was going to be
very involved in 2022
uh and he's getting involved right now
Lauren bobert has actually said she has
already asked Donald Trump to go to her
district and do a rally for her if Trump
gets involved to that level it is going
to be quite a midterm and indeed I think
it is going to be quite a midterm also
the choice of this district is
interesting because let's be Frank this
is a very easy race and Trump is big on
his record now he lies about his
endorsement record Trump has previously
said he's like uh you know what do you
say 150 in one or something his record
is actually not that good he mostly
endorses incumbents and still I think he
only had like a 60-something percent
vote success record with endorsements
but this is a really easy one if you
want to put points on the board and then
use those points to justify running
yourself in 2024 no Democrat has been uh
the representative for Colorado's Third
District since 2008. that was John
Salazar if you go before 2008 and
remember the elections are every two
years in the house if you you go before
2008 you've got to go back to 1992 for
this the last Democrat to hold that seat
so in other words since 1992
one Democrat has held thirds uh District
of Colorado and it's otherwise all
Republicans you look at the demographics
it's 65 percent rural very favorable to
Republicans it's 71 percent white pretty
favorable uh to to Republicans although
not not as crazy skewed as some other
districts it is considered in the cook
political report political values index
a republican plus six race and when you
consider other factors including the
power of incumbency that's a pretty
solid Republican seat so one of the
things we will be paying attention to is
okay Trump's going to be involved he's
going to be doing endorsements is he
disproportionately doing them in the
safest of safe districts he is endorsing
some Challengers but is he mostly
endorsing incumbents all of this is
stuff that we're going to follow but
number one it's clear he wants to be
involved and number two these trumpian
races May very much influence what the
Republican Party decides to do in 2024
and whether Donald Trump will even run
earlier this week we interviewed Michael
Cohen Michael Cohen said Donald's not
running in 24. and he's not running
because he can't afford the hit to his
ego to lose again
the counter would be and it's not about
who's right or wrong there's no right or
wrong yet because it hasn't happened
they're just predictions the counter
would be Trump ends up believing he can
easily win everything and so that may be
a factor in him deciding to run but Step
One is we don't even have to worry about
24 we're going to look at Trump's record
in 22. we'll look at how he's welcomed
in 22 and we'll look at how involved he
gets so this is the first one let me
know who you think he will endorse next
we will have more on the endorsements
and the 2022 campaign on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
you can also find me on Instagram at
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
and be back with much more
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple people are busy
we're not always getting effective
balanced nutrition from the food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple I've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything I'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athletic greens.com Pacman the link is
in the podcast notes